تحيه للمنتخب المغربي هنيئا لمنتخب المغرب
رغم الخساره رغم الخروج من المنافسه على
لقب كاس العالم ولكن لو سالتني قبل شهر هل
كانت المغرب ستكون في هذا الدور من كاس
العالم
هل ربما المغرب ممكن ينافس على كاس العالم
او لو جئت قلت لك يعني نحنا بعد شهر من
الان راح نكون زعلانين من المغرب ما اخذ
كاس العالم كان ممكن تتهمني في ذلك الوقت
بالجنون ولكن حدث او حصل الحلم الكبير
اللي عشناها مع المنتخب المغربي من
البدايه من مباراه كرواتيا الى بلجيكا الى
كندا الى اسبانيا البرتغال واخيرا فرنسا
ولكن هذه كره القدم بالنهايه تلعب على
جزئيات بسيطه في فريق بيكون بيومه في فريق
الكره عنده ظروف اخرى بتخليه مش بيومه
وبالتالي في فريق بينتصر على فريق
بالنهايه وبيوصل الى النهائي وهو هذا
الفريق طبعا كان فرنسا اليوم على المنتخب
المغربي
وكانت نتيجه طبعا هدفين مقابل لا شيء اول
بتبلش بتحيل اللاعبين جميعا تحيه للجماهير
المغربيه تحيه لوليد الرجراجي وتحيه لكل
من ساهم بهذا الحلم لكل من ساعد بان
المغرب يصل الى هذا الدور
لكل مين هندس هذه التجربه الرائعه واللي
ما راح تنسى بتاريخ الكره العربيه
والافريقيه والمغربيه
بالانتقال الى ما حدث بالمباراه اليوم
اختار ينزل همم طريقه اشبه بالتلاته اربعه
ثلاثه او اقرب ثلاثه اربعه ثلاثه بوجود
سايس وليامق وداري في الدفاع الى جانب
طبعا حكيمي مزراوي وامرابط وهمم واناحي
وثلاثه الهجوم الطبيعه لكل عارفينه طبعا
هذه الخطاب باول 21 دقيقه اثبتت انه كانت
خطه غير ناجحه انا براي شخص انه
يختار انه يبدا بهذا الخطه لانه اجنحته مش
جاهزه بدنيا لحتى ترجع تسال الدفاعيا وهذا
اللي شفناه بالشوط الثاني بشكل كبير
الاجنحه ما كانت ترجع تساند بالطريقه اللي
شفناها اليوم بالمباريات السابقه وباوامر
من وليد الركراكي انه يخليكم بالامام
هاجموا لا ترجعوا لوراء اعتقد انه زياش
وابو فهل ما كانوا جاهزين بدنيا وهذا
بيفسر ايضا تبديل بوفاه المبكره بالمباراه
همم طبعا مثل ما حكينا الخطه هاي ما كانت
ناجحه لانه وسط الملعب عند المنتخب
المغربي كان مكشوف ما شفنا اغلاق للعمق
وبتاع للمنتخب الفرنسي كان بيلعب بالشكل
اللي بده اياه طبعا اضف الى ذلك الاخطاء
الفرديه بالهدف الاول الاجابه للمنتخب
الفرنسي وسوء التغطيه وهو طبعا كان في
ملاحظه على همم لاعبيه او مدافعين المنتخب
المغربي انه لما مبابي يستلم الكره او لما
لاعب فرنسي يستلم الكره داخل منطقه الجزاء
بتلاقي انه فجاه كل لاعبي المغرب صاروا
اللاعب لحامل الكره وفي لاعب كره متروك
فاضي وهذا اللي صار بهدف الاول وصار ايضا
بالهدف الثاني اللي تسجل بالشوط الثاني
سجل البديل طبعا لذلك كان في امر غير
مفهوم بتمركز لاعبين المغرب او مدافعين
المغرب في هذه المباراه
خصوصا باول 21 دقيقه طبعا سايس انصاب
نتمنى له الشفاء العاجل وتبدل وتغير شكل
الفريق او عاد للاربعه ثلاثه بدخول املاح
تحسن شكل الفريق بشكل كبير شفنا المغرب
اخطر شفنا المغرب اكثر استحوادا المنتخب
الفرنسي كان وراء ناطر الهجمه المرتده
لحتى يضرب فيها المنتخب المغربي ولكن
المغرب كان مشكلته انه مش قادر يوصل
للمرمى بسبب سوء التعامل بالثلث الامامي
وخصوصا من قبل زي اشهر
المباراه الثانيه حاول يستدرك بعض الامور
واخرج مزراوي مش عارف هل هو مزراوي متجهز
بدنيا ايضا اعتقد ذلك ولكن خروج مصراوي
كان ضروري وبراي شخص كلازم بيبدا بيعطيوه
الله من بدايه المباراه من الشوط الاول
كنا ملاحظين انه عطيه الله راح يكون انفعه
افيد للمنتخب المغربي بالحاله الهجوميه من
مزراوي وهو ما كان فعلا في شرطه المباراه
الثاني عطيه الله قدم اداء كبير جدا
التبديد اللي مستغربه واللي صراحه يعني
اثر بشكل كبير على نتيجه المباراه
النهائيه هو تبديل يوسف النصيري بعبد
الرزاق حمد الله بدقيقه 66 هذا تبديل غير
مفهوم اذا كان نصيري قادر يكمل مباراه كان
لازم يكمل بلا شك لانه حمد الله يعني
بصراحه سيء جدا بالتعامل بالثلث الامامي
مع الكره واهضر فرصه كان ممكن تكون هدف
محقق للمنتخب المغربي واهدر اكثر من كره
كانوا كان شكل خطوره على المغرب لان الشوط
الثاني المغرب حرفيا اكتسح المنتخب
الفرنسي اكتساح حصلوا بمناطقوا وهو شيء لم
نكن نحن به انه منتخب عربي يحاصر فرنسا
نهائي كاس العالم بمناطقها وما يخليها
تعرف تطلع من منطقتها بشكل سلس ومريح
من جانب المنتخب الفرنسي اللاعب لازم تشد
فيه بالتاكيد هو جريزمان انطوان جريزمان
اللي قدم مباراه كبيره وقدم مونديال كبير
عامه غريزمان كان هو اللاعب لاعب يوصل بين
الخطوط كان هو اللاعب يطلع بالكره كان عم
يفتك كرهتك كثير بالنسبه للمنتخب الفرنسي
وهو كان اهم لاعب في منظومه المنتخب
الفرنسي بلا شك وبلا جدا
نحد كثير من خطورته مع انه كان عم يلعب
على انه يفتح مساحات بدون كره رونالدو على
الجهه اليسرى ولكن حتى لما كان يستلم
الكره ما كان خطير لانه مدافع اي منتخب
المغرب كانوا قادر يتعاملوا معه بالشكل
المطلوب بنهايه الامر هاي امور فنيه
وتكتيكيه تلعب عليها مباريات كره القدم
وخصوصا المباريات الكبرى في كره القدم مثل
نصف نهائي كاس العالم بيلاعب على جزئيات
بسيطه جدا وعلى امور بسيطه جدا اخطاء
فرديه سوء تمركز حاله من عدم التركيز امام
المرمى بتروح عليك تاهل وهذا ما حدث اليوم
مع المنتخب المغربي
كان افضل من فرنسا بمعظم دقائق المباراه
وكان اخطر من فرنسا باستثناء اول 21 دقيقه
اللي كانت المغرب عم تلعب فيهم بشكل اقرب
للثلاثه اربعه ثلاثه
بالنهايه مبروك قبل هاردلك لجماهير
المنتخب المغربي مبروك لجماهير المنتخب
الفرنسي الان النهائي بين فرنسا
والارجنتين نهائي قوي نهائي صعب وممتع
وارجو طبعا ان المنتخب المغربي ينجح بانه
يحصل على المركز الثالث بالبطوله لانه راح
يكون طبعا انجاز
هذا المجهود اللي قدمه على مدار البطوله
هاردك الجماهير المغربيه ومعوضين خير
[موسيقى]